et pour en parler nous sommes ce soir en
direct avec oula kunje gilles yabi
économistes et analystes politiques
également au fondateur de what is est un
think tank citoyens de l'afrique de
l'ouest bonsoir merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous sur rt trans quelle est
l'ambiance ce soir en côte d'ivoire on
voit les les injonctions en tout cas de
l'opposition à ne pas reconnaître cette
élection et le pouvoir qui mettent en
garde contre toute tentative de
déstabilisation
oui bonsoir je crois que ceux conçus à
quoi on assiste en côte d'ivoire c'est
un peu la chronique d'une crise annoncée
il même d'une crise aux grammy dans le
sens où on attendait une élection dans
des conditions très tendue avec des
incidents de sécurité dans différents
endroits
les rapports d'organisations la société
civile et notamment qui a observé les
élections parle d'au moins 15 morts
l'opposition parle de 30 morts mais ce
qui est évident c'est qu'on a eu un
niveau de violence qui est assez rare
finalement le jour même de l'élection
on avait déjà eu des incidents violents
avant l'élection 1 30 une trentaine de
deux morts dont peut-être au total déjà
et donc c'est là je pense témoigne de la
de la crispation en côte d'ivoire est à
nouveau
malheureusement du fait que les
conditions politiques pour cette
élection très controversée ont été créés
depuis longtemps il ya une fraction on
le voit c'est ce que nous dit et notre
correspondante sur place entre le nord
et le sud également oui mais je crois
que ce serait une analyse trop simpliste
qui nous écarterait du coeur du problème
qui est un problème politique
je couche je crois nouveau qu'on
n'assiste pas quelque chose de
surprenant
tout le monde sait que un des éléments
majeurs de l'aggravation des tensions
politiques a été la décision du
président ouattara au terme de ses deux
mandats constitutionnels dessus
présenter à nouveau et je crois que bien
sûr il ya d'autres problèmes de
faiblesse institutionnelle
il ya aussi une responsabilité politique
partagée entre tous les grands acteurs
de la vie politique ivoirienne de ses 21
années alassane ouattara a fait partie
tout comme henri konan-bédié laurent
gbagbo a exigé hommes soro mais je crois
que la responsabilité particulière
d'alassane ouattara est aujourd'hui
quand même très clair et je crois qu'il
faut le il faut le dire on savait très
bien qu'en à la houle à l'élection dans
ce contexte là avec un président qui se
présente pour un troisième mandat
évidemment on allait avoir de très
fortes tensions et compte tenu du rôle
que alassane ouattara jouer dans la
longue crise politique du pays
on pouvait pas s'attendre nous on a eu
notre réaction de la part de ses
adversaires politiques
il ya eu beaucoup de forces de sécurité
également pour contenir ces violences
qui reste néanmoins pas comparable à
celle qu'il y avait eu en 2010 les
ivoiriens aujourd'hui sont résignés
selon vo on leur a demandé de rester
chez eux
est ce que les rues sont désertes alors
je ne suis pas sur le terrain inconnu
armé mettrait tous les tous les
reportages et tous les tous les contacts
témoigne du fait que beaucoup
d'ivoiriens au même se sont déplacés en
a disons avant le jour du scrutin par
crainte de de violence et donc les
risques étaient connus était très connu
de la part du pouvoir également dû au
fond le pouvoir politique en place comme
dans d'autres pays a fait le pari disons
qu'ils auraient des incidents qui
auraient sans doute une participation
d'un limité mais qu'au fond ils
passeraient malgré tout un peu en force
et moi si vous savez je connais de cette
région et qu'on a observé la côte
d'ivoire sur la longue durée
on a observé deux pays de la région en
extrêmement désolé et attristé de voir
qu'à chaque élection présidentielle on
ne parle que des risques de violence et
que en plus entre les conditions
politiques pour pc violents se
concrétise crois qu'on doit aller au
diable les violences sont la conséquence
de deux personnalités politiques qui
veulent briguer d'autres mandats que
nous le permettait la précédente
constitution
oui exactement exactement je crois à
nouveau qu'il faut revenir sur les
conditions politiques de la violence qui
ont été créés et au fond on peut pas
créer les conditions de la violence il
espère y échappe ni et la question du
troisième mandat et les centrales disons
dans la le niveau de crispation actuelle
et je répète qu'il s'agit pas simplement
de voir les choses en terme de
pouvoir versus opposition en réalité on
parle de toute une population qui a une
très grande diversité politique mais
aussi on le sait être nos culturel et
dans ces conditions on savait très bien
une élection avec alassane ouattara est
en face kouadio bertin n'allait pas
mobilisés et n'allait pas être considéré
qu'une élection crédible malgré cela le
pouvoir y aller en sont parfaitement
conscients à nouveau que ce soit une
élection qui sans doute aggraverait la
diffusion plutôt que de constituer un
début de réconciliation
on attend également les chiffres de la
participation qui n'ont pas encore été
rendues officielles il faut atteindre
50% des des suffrages pour valider cette
élection vous qu'on sait qu'ils seront
un temps je ne pense pas qu'ils aient
feu ce seuil acquis qui s'impose il faut
50 % pour que le couple ouattara qui au
premier tour je ne peux pas justement
que le pouvoir
finalement de soucis à trop du taux de
participation en tout cas on fait en
sorte qu'ils ne soient pas extrêmement
bas c'est un peu étonnant qu'on commence
à donner les résultats provisoires de
l'élection sans connaît une estimation
assez précise du taux de participation
généralement le taux de participation
est la première donnée on peut donner
assez rapidement a juste après le après
le code et donc cela aussi ajoutent un
peu à la perception tête de manque de
crédibilité des résultats qui seront
données et du taux de taxation qui va
être annoncé très clairement on n'est
pas au bout de la de la crise électorale
à un coût du kwh on va suivre cela bien
sûr merci beaucoup et où la couv neige
il y habite avoir répondu ce soir à nos
questions sur arte france